اذا نذهب مباشره الى زميلتنا سمر بشات
مراسله مساء العربيه ومعها الموسيقى تامر
كروان يسعد مساكم واهلا بكم معنا في مسائل
عربيه وبلغي لنا تحياتنا لاستاذ تامر يا
سمر تفضلي يا سمر
[موسيقى]
سهام مساء الخير يا نادين تحياتنا هو
سامعكم تامر كروان
الموسيقار الكبير النهارده معانا زي ما
انت ذكرتي اعمال كثيره في لساني
تاريخ كبير من الموسيقى انا قبل السنه دي
هو بيعمل
رساله الامام وبيعمل مسلسل بطوله يسرا الف
الف حمد لله على السلامه
عايزه الاول قبل ما ندخل او ما ندخل في
رساله الامام ازاي الخصوصيه بتاعه هذا
النوع من الفن الموسيقى اللي بتقدمها انها
انت بتكتب لفيلم بتكتب لمسلسل
هنا بيبقى الهارمن ازاي ما بينك وما بين
المخرج علشان تقدروا توصلوا الاحساس
والرساله بين الموسيقى وبين الصوره او
العمل اللي احنا شايفينه
الاول كل سنه وانتم طيبين وسعيد ان انا
على البرنامج مساء العربيه
السؤال
ازاي بنوصل ان احنا نعمل موسيقى
للفيلم او المسلسل لازم اولا بيبقى فيه
تفاهم تام ما بين المخرج والمؤلف الموسيقي
على نوعيه الموسيقى من الاول
[موسيقى]
تاني حاجه بيبقى
الموسيقى دورها ايه في المسلسل
[موسيقى]
الموسيقى دورها ايه في المسلسل بتعمل ايه
بتاثر على المشاهد ازاي
تالت حاجه هو ان احنا بنجرب بنقعد نجرب
لغايه ما بنوصل للتوليفه اللي تناسب
المسلسل ده ساعات التجربه بتبقى سريعه
وساعات بتاخذ وقت عقبال ما نوصل
سهام نادين عايزين تسالوا حاجه احنا عندنا
اسئله كتير يعني ويا ريت نقدر نلخصها في
سريعا بدايه تامر يعني نحن كصحفيين مثلا
نكتب للصوره عندما نريد ان نكتب تقرير
اخباري هل هذا مشروط ايضا في مساله
التاليف الموسيقى التصويريه للافلام
والاعمال الدراميه يجب ان تتطابق الموسيقى
مع الحدث مع المشهد
[موسيقى]
والله هو في الموسيقى بالذات عشان فن مجرد
فبيبقى
يعني مش زي ان انا بكتب كلام لصوره لا لما
بكتب موسيقى الموسيقى نفسها
تلقي المشاهد بيبقى مختلف تلقي المستمع
يعني بيبقى مختلف فلما بحط نوعيه موسيقى
معينه على المشهد بيدي طاقه تانيه خالص
غير لما لما يعني هو ده اللي بيخلي
الموسيقى متفرده في الفنون انها فن
تاثيره على المشاهد غير مفهوم يعني بيبقى
تاثيره سمعي وتاثيره على الوجدان وتاثيره
بيخلق حالات من من الشجن من غير ما يقول
كلمه فبالتالي بيبقى عشان اقدر
اقصر واقدر بيبقى خط رفيع جدا في التاليف
الموسيقي للدراما وللسينما بالذات لان لو
انا شتيت شويه ممكن
يحصل تاثير عكسي اللي مش عايزينه احنا في
كاسرنا العمل يعني قبل ان تؤلف موسيقى
تصويريه لاي مسلسل هل تشاهد حلقات من
المسلسل قبل عرضه هل تقرا السيناريو حتى
تدخل في الجو درامي لمسلسل انا بدنا احنا
والمشاهدين نفهمه
طبعا لازم اقرا السيناريو
او ما تيسر منه لان طبعا بيبقى لسه ما
اتكتبش كله تاني حاجه لازم اتفرج على اكبر
قدر من المشاهد المهمه في المسلسل لان
احنا طبعا منظومه الانتاج في الوطن العربي
بتاخر التصوير لغايه اخر ميعاد في التسليم
فبالتالي انا ما بقدرش اتفرج على هو طبعا
الاحسن ان انا اتفرج على المسلسل كله
واشتغل على المسلسل كله لكن طبعا ده مش
متاح فبتفرج على اكبر قدر عشان اخد الطاقه
اللي موجوده جوه الصوره وطريقه طريقه اداء
الممثل بيفرق طريقه
المونتاج بيفرق طريقه التصوير بتفرق
فبالتالي انا اقدر اعمل موسيقى تتناسب
بشكل كبير جدا مع العمل اللي انا بعمله
يعني
طيب
[موسيقى]
ايوه بس انا كمان عندي سؤال انه بخصوص
رساله الامام اه لانه اكثر المسلسلات
شعبيه
وايضا جدلا في رمضان فاذا كمان حابين نسمع
هيك اللحن الموسيقي لرساله الامام اليوم
معك
هو كان اللحن الموسيقي كان بيقول لي كمان
انت عملته بطريقه ماضر شويه يعني هو
المسلسل بالذات يعني احنا انا وليس حجو
يعني اتفقنا ان احنا مش عايزين نعمل
الموسيقى التقليديه اللي هي
للمسلسلات التاريخيه والدينيه
اللي هي استخدام الالات الشرقي بكثره
الاستخدام الدفوف والحاجات دي يعني حاولنا
نبعد عن ده استخدمناها بس استخدمناها
بطريقه عصريه شويه بحيث انها تتناسب مع
حتى هو ليس عامل صوره صوره عصريه جدا
لمسلسل تاريخي وديني يعني فبالتالي التيمه
انا عشان بس الفيل مزيكا زاد شغال
فمش عارف افتكر
ههه انا نسيت اللحمه ههه هفتكرها بس كده
ههه طب انا عندي سؤال استاذ تامر مدامك عم
تدور على لحن وحياك طيب المده الزمنيه
طلبها تاليف موسيقى تصويريه يعني سمعنا
انه مسلسل الاختيار مثلا اتطلب الشغل فيه
شهر شهرين ونصف حسب ما عرفت
شهرين ونص تاليف وتقريبا
نصف شهر من
البرودكشن يعني ان انا اسجل مع
الاوركستراد واسجل الالات السولو اه طبعا
بس بس ساعات الواحد بيبقى معلش انا مديكم
ضهري بس ساعات بنبقى مضغوطين في الوقت
لدرجه ان احنا ممكن نخلص مسلسل في اسبوع
يعني
وبعدين بقى نتصرف بعد كده ايه اللي هيحصل
على التلفزيون المطلوب
الحقيقه طبعا ده كان
زي ما انتو قلتوا خد وقت كتير قوي فيلم
باب الشمس لانه فيلم ملحمي كبير وفيلم مش
سهل على جزئين وكل جزء بيدور في حقبه
زمنيه مختلفه يعني الجزء الاولاني كان
بيدور في فتره النقل
48 وبعد كده بعد اتفاقيه اصله في الجزء
الثاني طبعا نوع الموسيقى كان لازم مختلف
شويه فخدت فيه وقت كتير جدا عشان نوصل
للموسيقى المناسبه
على مقطوعه
رساله الايمان اهو خلاص
[موسيقى]
يعني هي المالد دي تحس انها انها مناسبه
للعصر اللي احنا فيه اكتر من العصر اللي
هو اللي بيدور فيه الاحداث وده كان مقصود
ان احنا نطلع بمالدي فيها روح الموضوع
طبعا مش بعيد عنه بس في نفس الوقت تبقى
تبقى
مناسبه للعصر اللي احنا فيه
اساسي ام كمالي للعمل
[موسيقى]
لا انا هنحاس طبعا عنصر اساسي
بصي هو هو تاريخ الموسيقى التصويريه هي ان
عشان الافلام الصامته قبل كده كانت
بتصاحبها موسيقى هي الحاجه الوحيده اللي
كانت بتاثر في المشاهد لان ما فيش حوار
فبالتالي ارتبطت شرطيا بالاعمال الدراميه
او السينمائيه وده بقى جزء اساسي من
التوليفه اللي هي بيسموها حتى الجريك
دراما لازم يبقى فيها الكواير او الجوكر
اللي بتغني عشان تدي الاحساس اللي مش مش
ممكن يديه التمثيل او الاخراج او العناصر
الاخرى
[موسيقى]
في نجاح العمل مع نجاحات العناصر الاخرى
لكنها تتنجحوا لوحده اشك بس ممكن تفشل عمل
[موسيقى]
طب ده بالنسبه لكل الاعمال يعني الدراما
زي السينما ولا هم مختلفين شويه لا طريقه
الشغل مختلفه شويه يعني السينما احنا
بنشتغل زي ما بيقولوا بنعمل ميوزك يعني
المزيكا بتبقى متصقه مع المشاهد تماما في
الدراما التلفزيونيه لطبيعه الانتاج في
الوطن العربي برده مش الانتاج كفلوس
الانتاج كطريقه انتاج ان ما بيبقاش عندنا
وقت ان احنا نعمل ميوزك فبالتالي بنعمل
كده في الميكساج عليكم
انتهى الوقت
شكرا شكرا
سهام كل سنه وانتم طيبين
[موسيقى]